when we were chatting earlier and you
said do you have a motorcycle
and i could tell first of all no one's
ever asked me that before because i
think
i don't seem like a motorcycle person
and the truth is i love motorcycles and
i have a motorcycle
and i ride it a lot and i
really enjoy it and i thought that's so
interesting
no one's ever asked me that but it's one
of the first
things secretary clinton asked me out of
the blue
and i happened to have a long ride
yesterday and was thinking this morning
about how much i enjoyed it
and it's almost like you you're just
curious you just want to know hey have
you ever done that yeah
yes i have well also when we were
talking you promised to
give me a ride you know either on the
back or in a sidecar and i'm going to
hold you to it
yeah i i think it would be such a great
i'm just love the photo op
we could put the microphones in our
helmets we could do the podcast
while we're on the road would that be
great this would be like
updating five easy pieces or something i
mean
the potential conan think of the
potential i think
you and i could sell that right now yes
they are so hungry for content can you
imagine how excited they'd be let's
let's get this pitch straight okay now
obviously it's your name first
because you're a historic figure and
revered so you're
first although you're crazy
alphabetically too yes also
although you know your criminal record
we'll have to look into that a little
more but
um i think that'll make us more
attractive yes yes
conan on the road with the ultimate
badass
world renowned criminal hillary clinton
you and i i'll ride the motorcycle you
and the side car
and uh or however you want to work it i
think we both need to be wearing
giant goggles because it's a funny look
of course and then
uh we stop occasionally leather i mean
we got to wear leather oh my god
leather don't you think wait a minute
yes yes i love it
if you're going to wear a leather biker
outfit i'm down for this
okay i am down for this yeah yeah do we
have to clear this
with your husband or chelsea
i mean i you know that that's all over
i'm done with all that public lifestyle